[Música]
si le recibió un primer envío de casi 2
millones de dosis de la vacuna contra el
coronavirus desarrollada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac el gobierno
planea implementar la inyección en todo
el país a partir de mediados de la
próxima semana un segundo envío de un
tamaño similar llegará el domingo
tenemos reportes desde santiago
enfrentamientos en la ciudad libanesa de
trípoli por cuarto día consecutivo entre
las fuerzas de seguridad y manifestantes
los ciudadanos expresan su ira y rechazo
a los confinamientos y cierres estrictos
impuestos por el gobierno para intentar
frenar la propagación del con 19 las
protestas de hannah hasta el momento una
persona fallecida y más de 200 heridos
y en francia y annie que estaba en ganó
por primera vez el bank the globe 2020
una de las regatas más difíciles del
mundo estaba incluso la línea de meta en
la tercera posición pero gracias un bono
de tiempo se quedó con el primer lugar
tenemos la historia de la emocionante
carrera en esta misión de noticias
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 sigue hablando
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en chile porque recibió su
primer cargamento de vacunas con mil un
millón 919 mil 800 dosis desarrolladas
por si no va a que el gobierno de
presidente chileno sebastián piñera
planea inocular a su población a partir
de mediados de la próxima semana está
previsto que un segundo lote de vacuna
similar al primero llega a la nación el
domingo 31 de enero la vacuna sinovac
fue aprobada por el regulador de salud
de chile para uso de emergencia el 20 de
enero
escuchamos parte de las declaraciones
del presidente piñera
la disponibilidad de la vacuna la
aprobación
y la decisión del ministerio de salud
nos permiten iniciar la próxima semana
probablemente el día miércoles después
de tener los certificados que acreditan
la seguridad de esta vacuna vamos a
poder iniciar en todas las regiones del
país un proceso de vacunación masiva
vamos precisamente hasta santiago la
capital chilena con nuestra corresponsal
patricia luna patricia muy buena noche
que más se sabe sobre este plan de
vacunación masivo
chile ya inició el pasado 24 de
diciembre fue uno de los primeros países
de américa latina en iniciar la
vacunación cuando llegaron las primeras
dosis de la vacuna facer sin embargo la
llegada masiva de estos 4 millones de
dosis en esta semana a los que se
sumarán unas dosis parecidas en la
primera quincena de febrero permitirá al
gobierno iniciar la vacunación en la
población más vulnerable con el objetivo
de lograr el ambicioso plan de vacunar a
5 millones de la población más más
vulnerable al cobit en los tres primeros
meses de este 2010 y 1 y a 15 millones
de chilenos en los seis primeros meses
de este año ahora patricia pero no toda
la población chilena está a gusto con
las vacunas de procedencia china le
pregunto cuál es la polémica en torno a
este tema
así es esta semana saltaba la polémica
cuando uno de los sindicatos de
trabajadores de la red privada del
hospital de temuco en el sur del país
afirmaba que a ellos se les había
prometido que se iban a inocular con la
vacuna de facer que es la que conocen y
que es aquella que les da más seguridad
y que por lo tanto no querían ser
vacunados con la vacuna china esto ha
generado muchísima polémica el colegio
médico del propio de la propia región de
temuco ha salido diciendo que se se
vacunará a la población con la vacuna
que esté disponible y el director del
instituto de salud pública respondía a
estos funcionarios afirmando que puede
enviar toda la información disponible en
formación que ha solicitado otros países
para implementar esta vacuna que es una
vacuna completamente es segura y qué
se utiliza un virus inactivado que no
hay ningún riesgo y que estos
comentarios responden por tanto a otros
objetivos y a otros fines sin embargo lo
mostrado por los funcionarios del
hospital de temuco responde también un
poco a la preocupación que existe en una
parte de la población chilena que no ve
con tan buenos ojos la vacuna china como
ve por ejemplo la vacuna de facer o la
de oxford que también fue aprobada esta
semana en el país
patricia como siempre gracias por toda
la información desde santiago la capital
chilena nosotros continuamos con más
información en nuestro noticiero y en
wuhan china los expertos internacionales
de la organización mundial de la salud
pudieron iniciar su investigación en el
origen sobre el origen del coi 19 en
dicha ciudad ocurrió el primer brote
hace poco más de un año china puso
obstáculos desde el principio para
llevar a cabo esta investigación
independiente pero finalmente acordó
cooperar con el equipo de la oms no
obstante la potencia asiática advirtió a
eeuu sobre no interferir políticamente
en esta misión
hoy los
y terminaron sus cuarentena de 14 días
[Música]
otra noche de protestas en la ciudad
libanesa de trípoli desde el lunes
centenares de personas se manifiestan
contra la cuarentena estricta impuesta
por el gobierno para frenar la pandemia
en una de las ciudades del líbano más
golpeadas por la pobreza por ahora más
de 200 personas están heridas y al menos
un manifestante perdió la vida veamos el
informe
harta y confinada la gente volvió a
salir a las calles de trípoli por cuarta
noche consecutiva la indignación por las
restricciones contra la pandemia y el
consecuente empobrecimiento de la
población llevó a centenares de personas
a manifestarse unas manifestaciones que
se convirtieron en violentos
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad cócteles mólotov disparos
centenares de heridos entre el miércoles
y el jueves y al menos un muerto
lo que llevo a trípoli a esta situación
es que todas las otras ciudades se
enriquecieron a costa de trípoli no
tenemos donde ir no tenemos educación y
atracciones turísticas el resto del
mundo puede protestar sin que le disparé
porque nosotros no la ira de la gente
esta llosa por la unnoba y stop las
autoridades aseguran que la represión
contra las protestas era necesaria igual
que la nueva cuarentena estricta sobre
trípoli que agrava la peor crisis
económica que vive el líbano
la gente está cansada es pobre vive en
la miseria y con la cuarentena no hay
trabajo
para los taxistas repartidores y
vendedores ambulantes el confinamiento
significa quedarse sin ingresos de hecho
la mitad del país trabaja en empleos
informales día a día
la crisis económica se superpone con la
sanitaria los hospitales luchan contra
la pandemia sin suministros suficientes
y cada vez hay menos camas disponibles
vamos ahora hasta el continente europeo
cientos de mujeres y hombres continúan
sus protestas en las calles de varsovia
la capital polaca luego de que entrara
en vigor la sentencia del tribunal
constitucional que prohíbe la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo por
malformación fetal la corte argumenta
que un no nacido goza también del
derecho a la vida y asegura que
actualmente es posible hacer un
tratamiento oportuno para evitar
posibles malformaciones la decisión
endurece aún más la legislación polaca
sobre el aborto y ahora sólo será legal
en caso de violación o incesto y riesgo
para la vida de la madre
el regatista francés gianni que estaba
en fue declarado ganador de la regata
vendée globe best avn fue el tercero en
cruzar la línea de meta pero un jurado
le otorgó una compensación de tiempo de
10 horas y 15 minutos por ayudar a
rescatar a un compañero competidor
veamos esta historia
después de 80 días en el mar y 12 largos
años de espera y anif estaba en ha
regresado de manera gloriosa ha
conseguido la victoria en la donde glock
la regata de vela más dura del mundo
[Aplausos]
siento que estoy soñando no parece real
es extraño pasar de estar totalmente
aislado a esto la fiesta los fuegos
artificiales la gente que ha salido a
pesar de las difíciles circunstancias
todavía no me creo lo que ha pasado sigo
pensando en la carrera aunque ya terminó
este era mis sueños desde la infancia
la contrarreloj en solitario sin escalas
por el océano atlántico que pasa más
allá de los tres cabos y regresa
cruzando el atlántico otra vez tuvo su
final más cercano con cinco capitanes
todavía en la carrera en el último día
al final fue el bonus de tiempo debe
estar en lo que marcó la diferencia se
le otorgó por cambiar de rumbo para
participar en el dramático rescate de
kevin scofield después de que su bote se
partiera en 2
el primer intento debe estar en 2008 no
podía haber sido peor después de apenas
30 horas en el mar perdió su mástil y
tuvo que rendirse pero mantuvo vivo el
sueño y continuó participando en
carreras costeras y transatlánticas
ganando algunas de ellas emprendedor e
ingeniero de formación de estaban dejó
su huella en la bandera incluso antes de
esa victoria soñada el generador
hidroeléctrico que desarrolló se ha
convertido en estándar en todos los
barcos de la competición
un buen gesto y su buen desempeño le
aseguraron la victoria hasta que el
informativo de france 24 continue con
nosotros y feliz noche para todos hasta
pronto
[Música]